nelson mandela used to say
i quote in a globalized world
we are the keepers of our brothers and
sisters especially
in the arena of health end of quote
the corona pandemic has confirmed how
right he was
we can only contain the virus by joining
forces with our friends
in other countries and continents we
must step
up the world's capacity to produce
vaccines
as well as our collective preparedness
against health crisis
the world was not prepared for a global
pandemic of this
unprecedented scale but we have acted
last year we went from hearing for the
first time about covet 19
to fast tracking r d we expanded our
testing capacity exponentially
and managed to bring several vaccines to
the market
and we did this in record time
this is remarkable
but we must now move from the attack
solutions
of this year towards a sustainable
system
and this will help us manage and prevent
health crises
in the future this is exactly the goal
of the global health
summit that i will co-host with italy on
may 21st at this summit
we will agree on principles that can
guide our future responses
you